madame monsieur bonjour voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce 12 13
le sort du septennat est en jeu 40
millions de français sont appelés aux
urnes pour se prononcer sur la réduction
à 5 ans du mandat présidentiel la
campagne du référendum n'a pas passionné
les citoyens nous ferons le point sur la
participation à la mi-journée en
yougoslavie c'est l'avenir politique de
slobodan milosevic qui est un enjeu des
élections présidentielle et législatives
sous haute tension pour la première fois
de son histoire
l'opposition yougoslave peut l'emporter
le conquerront 30 médailles dans
l'escarcelle tricolore ce matin les
français ont remporté cinq nouveaux
trophées lors en aviron et en vtt avec
miguel martinez le premier champion
olympique français de cette discipline
au lendemain du dramatique accident
survenu lors du rallye automobile de
cerisiers dans l'yonne le bilan est
désormais de cinq morts et cinq blessés
graves parmi les victimes un enfant et
le pilote de la subaru qui a perdu le
contrôle de sa voiture
ce rallye avait déjà été endeuillé il y
à 7 ans par un accident mortel
luc lahaye a mouché c'est vers 14h30
hier que marco massarotto perd le
contrôle de son véhicule après avoir
franchi une bosse la voiture sort de la
route et percuté un pylône électrique
qui s'abat sur les spectateurs
bilan 5 morts dont le pilote et un
enfant et huit blessés dont cinq graves
deuxième au classement avec 49 secondes
de retard sur le leader le pilote corse
était à l'attack peut-être trop à mon
avis il était beaucoup trop vite le
pilote
bon il allait il était revenu presque
égalité avec jalousie non qui voulait
faire il voulait faire la tendance est
spéciale mais bon c'est cette bosse elle
ne passe pas fond avec n'importe quelle
voiture
immédiatement les preuves qui compte
pour la coupe de france des rallyes est
interrompue c'était la 13e édition du
rallye de l'yonne un rallye déjà
endeuillée en 1993 par la mort d'un
spectateur fauché par une voiture
les organisateurs étaient donc
sensibiliser et certifie avoir tout mis
en oeuvre pour assurer la sécurité de la
compétition
c'est pas à nous de dire ce qu'il s'est
passé il ya une enquête
maintenant tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que pour ce qui concerne l'organisation
du rallye les secours intervenus tous
qui proprement dit organisation
il n'y a absolument aucun reproche à
faire une enquête judiciaire et donc
ouverte
elle va tenter d'éclaircir les
circonstances du drame éventuellement
d'établir les responsabilités car cet
accident repose une nouvelle fois le
problème de la sécurité des compétitions
automobiles disputation route en deux
ans dix spectateurs et trois pilotes
sont morts lors d'épreuves de rallye de
pise hier cinq noms supplémentaires
s'ajoutent sur satis macabre les bureaux
de vote sont donc ouverts jusqu'à ce
soir 18 heures 40 millions d'électeurs
sont appelés à se prononcer sur la
réduction du mandat présidentiel selon
toute vraisemblance le septennat en
vigueur depuis 127 ans va disparaître le
quinquennat est en effet défendu par la
majorité des grandes formations de
droite comme de gauche
mais l'enjeu du scrutin est avant tout
la mobilisation des citoyens
les principaux leaders politiques ont
d'ores et déjà à donner l'exemple en
accomplissant leur devoir électoral
les partisans du non comme charles
pasqua les militants du oui comme le
premier ministre qui a voté ce matin en
haute garonne et le président de la
république qui lui a voté en corrèze le
tour des bureaux de vote des
personnalités avec marc précaire le
président de la république jacques
chirac et son épouse bernadette chirac
ont voté tous deux à 11h30 à saran le
couple présidentiel il possède en effet
une résidence secondaire est l'épousé du
chef de l'état
il est adjoint au maire petit café
matinal avant d'accomplir son devoir
électoral
le premier ministre costume gris sourire
aux lèvres le chef du gouvernement a
voté en présence du maire socialiste et
de nombreux journalistes
une heure avant le vote vers 8 heures un
barrage filtrant avait été mise en place
par des agriculteurs et les artisans
pour protester contre le prix du
carburant souriant et détendu aussi jean
pierre chevènement
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur est lui
bel fera beauté à 8h30 dans son fief
tout aussi sourire plus que ce gain a
voté ce matin à epinal dans les vosges
où il est dit
à devoir civique rapidement effectué les
partisans du non au référendum se sont
levés de bonne heure jean marie le pen
le président du front national a voté
dès 9 heures dans le 15e arrondissement
quant à charles pasqua le président du
rassemblement pour la france il s'est
déplacé dès 10 heures dans son bureau de
vote de neuilly accompagné de son épouse
serait faire un homme a été marquée par
une petite campagne pour sans doute une
grosse abstention nous ferons le point
sur le taux de participation
on dirait du ministère de l'intérieur à
la fin de ce journal depuis des
décennies la vie politique française a
été rythmée par les référendum
l'algérie la nouvelle calédonie ou
encore maastricht c'est la neuvième
consultation depuis 1958 fabrice turpin
léon zitrone est déjà là il y as presque
quarante deux ans jour pour jour la vème
république est adoptée par référendum le
sauveur s'appelle une fois de plus de
gaulle une situation un scrutin qui
plaisent pas l'homme au point d'utiliser
le référendum comme une arme politique
ainsi en 1962 les français sont appelés
aux urnes à deux reprises une première
fois pour ratifier dans un climat
dangereux et difficile
les accords d'evian c'est l'indépendance
de l'algérie sept mois plus tard et
contre l'avis du parlement le président
sera élu au suffrage universel direct
les français de gaulle en ont décidé un
sou véritable plébiscite pour l'homme et
ses idées à chaque fois de gaulle fait
de ces consultations
une affaire personnelle et puis désavoué
le général de gaulle fera appel au
référendum à cinq reprises une fois de
trop 1969 année chaotique le général 120
la seule fois pour l'instant où les
partisans du non l'ont emporté l'exemple
sert de leçon les autres présidents de
la république utiliseront le référendum
avec beaucoup plus de prudence est
toujours à des moments clés comme en
1988 en plein climat de guerre civile en
nouvelle calédonie
la poignée de main entre jean marie
tjibaou et jacques lafleur est
historique c'est le début du processus
d'évolution d'un nouveau statut pour la
nouvelle calédonie dernier référendum en
date le traité de maastricht c'était il
ya huit ans après une campagne passionné
un scrutin serré le oui l'emporté de
justesse
aujourd'hui les français se prononcent
sur le quinquennat le 12e référendum de
toute l'histoire
on vote également en yougoslavie chez un
scrutin crucial pour l'avenir de
slobodan milosevic ces élections
présidentielle et législatives se
déroulent dans un climat de suspicion
générale le pouvoir et l'opposition
s'accusent mutuellement de vouloir
manipuler les résultats
une opposition donnée gagnante dans les
sondages pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la yougoslavie
stéphane du bain slobodan milosevic n'a
pas besoin d'isoloirs pour voter comme
lui sept millions et demi de serbes et
400000 monténégrins vote aujourd'hui et
pour la première fois en treize années
pouvoir milosevic et devancés dans tous
les sondages par l'opposition
recherché pour crimes de guerre il sait
que c'est sa survie politique qui est en
jeu mais aussi sa liberté
il a donc lui-même organisé ce scrutin
conséquence le monténégro appel au
boycott est les premiers on évite ch ont
donc installé les bureaux de vote chez
eux
vous avez vu ce que le gouvernement nous
oblige à faire il nous interdit d'avoir
des bureaux de vote officiel s'est donc
transformé mon salon en bureaux de vote
mais je ne vais pas voter pour qui vous
voulez vous que je vote
j'ai déjà voté trois fois pour milosevic
j'en ai marre
l'opposition compte donc sur la
lassitude et l'exaspération de la
population en serbie comme au monténégro
ou au kosovo
tous s'interrogent sur le résultat et
surtout sur la réaction de milosevic
tout dépendra vraiment de la réaction de
la population mais il est évident que
milosevic aura besoin de truquer ces
élections s'il veut gagner dès le
premier tour ce matin des irrégularités
ont déjà été constatées par un organisme
privé basé à belgrade
interdiction de vérification des listes
électorales et impossibilité de vérifier
si les yeux en était bien vide avant le
vote
son histoire a été occulté par la crise
des otages de joe lo couverte par les
médias du monde entier mais au même
moment une rennaise membres d'action
contre la faim était détenue en somalie
dans la plus grande discrétion capturé
le 26 juillet françoise deutsch vient
d'être libéré après huit semaines de
captivité
elle se repose actuellement en région
parisienne où ils ont rencontré jean
yves perron et jean jacques botti loin
des flashs et des caméras de roissy une
libération d'otages bien discrète malgré
les efforts de quelques amis françoise
était pourtant otage en somalie depuis
juillet kidnappée par une bande mafieuse
en compagnie d'un anglais dans une
maison désaffectée qui a été notre lieu
de détention pendant presque huit
semaines après physiquement pas de
maltraitance
du stress psychologique quelques mots
l'individu action contre la faim à
l'employeur de françoise choisi de
négocier dans la discrétion mais au même
moment la france fait le choix contraire
pour les otages des philippines et la
famille tout ce qu'ont suivie en même
temps ce qui se passait à joe lo ont
envoyé cette avalanche d'image cette
avalanche d'informations c'est comme
comme une débauche l'impression ou et
c'était une débauche pour nous et puis
pilote même temps on était là on se
disait fraction de seconde il nous met
françoise suivait également gelot à la
radio qui nous inquiétait un certain
moment c'est que cette médiatisation
cette surmédiatisation de jongh
sachant que les ravisseurs avaient aussi
accès à la radio donc ça peut être très
préjudiciable pour pour d'autres otages
et donné des idées à des preneurs
d'otages faut-il parler ou pas des
prises d'otages en tout cas pour les
amis de françoise les médias pourraient
au moins parler de sa libération
un entrefilet quand elle a été enlevée
rien du tout quand elle a été libérée
voilà alors du coup on s'est fait ma
propre monde voilà les français sont
encore récolté une belle moisson de
médailles ce matin sydney 5 nouveau
trophée de bronze d'argent et d'or lors
notamment pour miguel martinez qui est
devenu champion olympique de vtt
c'est le premier titre remporté par un
français dans cette discipline
introduite aux jeux d'atlanta il ya
quatre ans déjà vainqueur du championnat
du monde et de la coupe du monde
médiane martinez le fils de mariano
martinez meilleur grimpeur du tour de
france au 78ème maintenant d'entamer à
son tour une carrière sur route comme
papa les escrimeurs et les rameurs ont
également fait fort ce matin
en escrime l'équipe de sabre a remporté
la médaille d'argent
l'or et le bronze pour l'aviron qui a
décidément le vent en poupe quelques
coups drame ont suffi au 4 sans barreur
pour battre chez eux
les australiens à sydney dominique
champeau
au royaume des jeux aussi les médailles
appartiennent parfois à ceux qui se
lèvent tôt aux aurores olympiques ils
sont quatre à rêver d'un titre car trop
de travail pour six minutes à qui tout
au pour être tout de suite dans le
rythme il faut être concentré précis les
premières longueurs sont souvent
déterminantes et le chef de la géla pour
qu'aucun coup de pelle ne se perd
une fois le premier 500 passait depuis
mythe
parce qu'en bon peut-être que j'étais
rassuré sur la capacité de réaction du
bateau on était bien placés
ça allait mieux tout au long des deux
kilomètres du parcours les quatre
français n'ont eu qu'une obsession
concédé le moins de terrain possible aux
au sol une longueur en demi finale
c'était déjà trop là les deux bateaux
son bord à bord
à 500 mètres du podium les quatre
français sont inarrêtables
à un moment il dit ils sont cuits on y
va et puis là-bas on part et puis on les
passe au prix d'un effort terrible
le bateau cancer remontera centimètre
par centimètre son rival australien
l'épuiser mais heureux dormann hoc des
bêtes et porchier offre donc un aviron
france est une nouvelle consécration
olympique
du fil de l'eau au fil de la lame
l'esprit d'équipé rassemble les mêmes
vertus courage solidarité mais les
encouragements de damiatte uia n'auront
que peu d'effet les sabreurs français et
anglicans d'élus finale contre les
allemands n'ont jamais été en mesure
ensuite d'inquiéter les russes ils
s'inclinent 40 ça touche à trop de
dommages le sabre par équipes et dans
toute l'histoire des jeux le seul titre
qui manque encore à l'esprit français et
dernier et cocorico de la matinée avec
la médaille d'argent obtenue par eric
pouget de au cheval d'arçons c'est la
plus belle récompense gagné par la
gymnastique française depuis 1924 seul
henri boério philippe vatuone n'avait
ramené le bronze de montréal et de los
angeles
à seulement 28 ans éric poujade mètres à
6,1 brion point final à sa carrière
en revanche le cauchemar continue pour
l'équipe de france d'athlétisme après le
forfait de diagana la fuite de perec et
d'élimination de christine arron
un autre espoir de médaille cette
envolée la cuisse de nice a lâché et
barber a abandonné la championne du
monde en titre d'heptathlon est la
dernière victime de la spirale infernale
qui touchent les athlètes tricolores
reportage sur place serge djian de nos
villes
la souffrance physique et morale est
trop fort eunice barber va bientôt
renoncer
la championne du monde en titre de
l'heptathlon effectué qu'un saut en
longueur à seulement 5 mètre
quatre-vingt-treize pourtant avant les
épreuves de la 2e journée l'espoir
tenait encore la valeur valeur
l'attend dès l'échauffement justement
pour tester un peu sa cuisse et puis
voir si tout était encore possible en
terme de points quand on connaît le
patron tout était possible
après l'échec du saut en longueur les
entraîneurs partent à la recherche
d'eunice barber participera-t-elle aux
deux dernières épreuves le javelot puis
le 800 m
la rémoise a regagné le stade
d'échauffement au téléphone elle annonce
son abandon au directeur technique
national adjoint
que vous at elle dit très déçu
une tristesse à la hauteur des espoirs
nourris la veille à l'issue des deux
premières épreuves
eunice barber était largement en tête de
classement les sourires vont vite
devenir grimace blessé tout l'été
barber n'a pas pu s'entraîner
correctement elle aura tout essayé avant
d'abandonner la femme de matériel japon
comme ça c'est le sport est bon il ya
les blessures et
ea les victoires et les déceptions se
vend mal hein va-t-il tourner si
l'équipe de france d'athlétisme revenait
de signer sans médaille ce serait une
triste première aux jeux olympiques
en revanche tout va bien pour les
footballeur parisien le psg a pris la
tête du championnat de france hier soir
après sa victoire sur nantes de buzeins
nicolas anelka et laurent robert ont
permis aux parisiens de réaliser une
belle opération
le psg compte désormais un point
d'avancé sur bastia qui a concédé le nul
à sedan monaco est allé battre metz
victoire également de bordeaux sur
toulouse
voilà le superbe but signé laurent
beurre la surprise vient de lyon bien
yvan s'est imposé à gerland ce soir le
derby du nord opposera lille à lens et
en cas de victoire les lensois reprend
non la tête au parisien mais voilà
pleine lucarne pour mickaël landreau
nous revenons à présent sur la
principale information de ce dimanche le
référendum en direct du ministère de
l'intérieur nous retrouvons michel
lemerle michel la principale question
concerne bien sûr la mobilisation des
français quels sont les premiers
chiffres de la matinée et bien pas de
miracles tous les chiffres que
laissaient entrevoir les mauvais
chiffres que laissait entrevoir les
sauvages se sont confirmées on a peu
voté ce matin en france le chiffre qui
vient de nous parvenir
9 44 % de participation c'est le record
absolu mais mon le référendum de
nouvelle calédonie en 88 où il y avait
eu 63 % d'abstention le matin plus de 10
% des électeurs s'étaient déplacés aux
urnes c'est la première fois qu'on a un
chiffre de participation à un seul
chiffre
et dans les villes qui sont en général
des villes qui passe pour ac civique
comme strasbourg juste un peu plus de
sept électeurs sur dix qui se sont
déplacés à rennes 6 95 où ils sont
vraiment de très mauvais chiffre alors
on peut espérer peut-être une légère
accélération cet après midi mais sans
trop d'illusions du point de vue de la
participation
ce référendum est vraiment mal parti
merci de michel lemaire pour finir la
météo avec vous florence
beau temps explique peut-être en partie
en tout cas ce fort taux d'abstention
même si ce dimanche sera moins
ensoleillées directement effectivement
on a eu un beau samedi donc tout le
monde peut-être envie de profiter des
derniers rayons du soleil il faut dire
que la pluie est déjà là et donc elle va
envahir cet après-midi un certain nombre
de régions
alors ce matin on l'a retrouvée du
cotentin au poitou charentes regarder
cet après midi à l'avancé et donc elle
sera modérée dans sa partie nord
elle sera beaucoup plus faible dans sa
partie sud cette perturbation à l'aria
retour de belles éclaircies avec des
cumulus et des averses localement
orageuses
à l'avant il fait toujours très très
beau simplement quelques petits cyrus
dans le ciel et quelques entrées
maritimes également sur le golfe du lion
et de températures seront toujours
douces et oui elles sont agréables et
c'est pour ça qu'on a envie de sortir et
de profiter tout cela alors elles
baissent un tout petit peu quand même
sur le nord-ouest mais elles seront
encore compris cet après midi entre 18
et 24 degrés sur la moitié sud 21 à 27
degrés c'est donc un temps effectivement
estivale et demain on peut peut-être
jeter un tout petit coup d'oeil sur la
carte de demain eh bien on voit cette
perturbation qui s'en va alors qu'une
nouvelle arrivée entre les deux un peu
de brouillard qui se dissipera merci
beaucoup c'est la fin de ce 12 13 merci
à vous de l'avoir suivi dans quelques
instants retour en direct à ciney je
vous retrouve ce soir pour un 19 20
spéciales référendum à partir de 19h30
excellent après midi à toutes et à tous
non
en direct